[Applause]
please welcome anthony anderson and his
mama
doris bowman
hi guys hey drew what's going on how are
you love
thank you so much for coming on the show
today we were so excited to talk to you
guys
oh well well my mama twisted my arm
because you know any time she gets a
chance she gets to be on tv
she jumps at it i'm so excited um
i'm a mom of two girls and i love
uh speaking to mamas and you two are
such an inspiration
what do you think not to jump right in
but what is the secret sauce
of being you know this mom and her son
that are working together you know
close to each other i give her bingo
money
drew i give her bingo money
uh that's why we're so close and that's
why this relationship
uh has lasted the test of time uh as
long as i keep bingo money in her
account
she's happy i'm happy to get a check too
every night
i bet you are i love it mama i mean
what was anthony like as a little boy
mischievous and smart but he was so
smart
was or still uh well he's still here
okay thank you i mean you
just go clear that up for the people
watching it at home yeah he was really
smart
i i still am this teacher said he was
gifted
and talented really yeah
he went from ninth grade to cal state
l.a
um yeah okay that's that's enough stop
with all the praising
i didn't know that you went from ninth
grade to college
yes my high school was on
a college campus is what my mom was
trying to say
but uh i i did i i was uh
in a lot of ap uh classes and uh
got to spend my uh high school years on
a college campus with with uh
you know uh college students uh studying
he got college credits too
yes i did mama because i was gifted and
talented yes
mama i just is it okay if i call you
mama yes
yes okay i just feel really cozy
uncomfortable and i want to nuzzle in
and call you mama
anthony is that okay it's okay but
you'll be regretting it soon enough drew
okay that's that's that's fine
you know you guys are both working to
bring awareness
to diabetes anthony and i know this is
very personal for you will you guys tell
me about this
well you know uh i was the first person
diagnosed with type 2 diabetes in my
family
and then uh my dad and then my mom
uh and we um subsequently lost my father
to complications from diabetes
uh so i partnered with uh novo nordisk
and and we started this campaign called
get real about diabetes
and everyone watching can go to our
website get real about diabetes.com
uh and and get the information that that
you need
uh to tell you about uh what it's like
uh to live with the disease uh how it is
that you can help
eradicate it or or live a better life uh
in ways to prevent from getting it uh so
we've um
it's near and dear to me uh and it's
something that
that i love to talk about and share
within the community uh because it's
something that needs to be spoken about
i'm so sorry about your dad um anthony
and mama and
i'm very grateful that you are able to
take your story and your journey
and have it have such a beneficial
effect on others and to be brave
enough to talk about it and bring people
into the conversation
and promote awareness and prevention
um you were 31 right anthony when you
got diagnosed
uh 30. uh yeah it's it's i just hit the
20-year mark now being
uh a diabetic yeah i wanted to talk to
you about
you know eating and food as well because
i know
you're a big foodie um so
you know how are you right now and
um how is everything going uh
everything's going fine uh
you know my numbers are great my a1c is
below seven uh as a type two diabetic
that
is uh at the top of the list uh but i i
love to eat uh i am a foodie i have a
garden in the backyard in the community
carton
of the block from the house um and you
know everything
is good in moderation you know and
sometimes
uh i i'll go overboard with the healthy
stuff and i'll i'll just be a vegan for
eight months out of the year
um and and and then i'll come back to
the meat
which is where i am right now uh i got
some meat marinating in the kitchen
right now
but uh ev everything is well you know i
try to keep my mother
in check i try to get her healthy and
moving around and she's doing a great
job at it
uh do you listen mama no no
i love it i can't do the vegan stuff
yeah i need some meat once a week yeah
ah
once yeah and leaves okay
at least
well i was very inspired by the fact
that you make a jalapeno
cheddar cornbread anthony that might be
one of my favorite foods
is this true yeah yes
no it's it's actually a bacon jalapeno
cheddar cornbread don't forget i throw a
little bacon in there now too uh
every now and again drew i just love
food so much and i love cooking and i've
recently
become a a gardener myself and
uh is it true that you um took a class
at the
cordon bleu i do i would take uh weekend
classes at codan
and just just just you know like i say
i'm a foodie i've always wanted to go to
culinary school
never carved out the time to do it uh so
i would go take weekend classes at
cordon blue
and uh you know learn you know how to
make stocks
you know learn how to cut up a chicken
and use every part of the chicken
uh learn how to make sauces uh and
things like that
but more importantly learning to
time your food that's where i was always
off
you know uh proper timing so everything
comes together at once so you're not
waiting on one thing to
uh to get done and the other thing is uh
sitting there waiting for you to to eat
it so
that that's what i went to cordon bleu
for to learn about uh
uh the proper timing in the kitchen i
need to go
to cordon bleu myself because i suck at
timing in the kitchen i'm like a one
focused dish
like a pasta a soup like i i'm i'm
much better at a one pot thing but i
just loved that about your
story and i'm just so happy to be with
you and mama